dr drew what's your overall reaction
that after 13 years brittany's father
has now officially been suspended well
my initial reaction is about time and i
anticipate they will probably undo the
conservatorship altogether i think
that's going to be the next step the
reality is the conservatorship in all
likelihood saved her life it was
absolutely necessary at one time it
suggests she had very very serious
mental illness and repeated mental
health evaluations have confirmed that
but that doesn't necessarily mean
somebody needs to be on a conservatory
ship indefinitely she's able to work she
has her own money she deserves a chance
to be off conservatorship you need to
only walk across the street here and you
can see people that need conservatorship
way more than britney spears
so
just put that in context was it time for
this to end and if so why it probably
went on a lot longer than it should have
and imagine you're the father and you
know your child has serious mental
illness your anxiety is going to keep
you in that the mental health
professionals have told you it saved her
life you can imagine you're going to
want to hang on to that the reality is
that is not an objective perspective
he's too invested in this process he's
not looking at her as an autonomous an
adult but she in spite of a mental
illness deserves a chance at autonomy
for sure now they can do it in such a
way that they follow her very carefully
there can be checks and balances
psychiatric follow-up that she has to
comply with and the judge can watch her
very carefully as she transitions into
the world there will be a transition
that's put into place for brittany
before the conservatorship officially
ends yes what does that need to look
like and what does brittany need in
place to successfully move forward none
of us really know exactly what's going
on with her we don't know her we're not
involved in her care right but we do
know that she was sick enough to need to
be in the hospital for weeks and had
serious enough mental illness to be put
on a conservatorship which is reserved
for the more serious mental illnesses
now she's done been stable for a long
time the issue will be does she remain
stable when she goes out into the world
can she come back for proper medication
checks follow up does she do what she's
supposed to do and i wonder what kind of
psychotherapeutic or behavioral
interventions they're going to put in
place as well that can help her
sort of identify and understand her
illness so she's motivated to stay with
her care how would you set up a
transition so that she doesn't spiral
down a road clearly medication or
important part of the game here i i
think you know one of the things i would
do is set up a directive i would say
brittany we've got to sit down you're
you're a sound mind right now but you
need to write in writing that you're
going to allow me to intervene if you
decompensate i can put you in the
hospital i can give you medication even
if you don't want it if it's in your
best interest in the opinion of multiple
physicians and we're going to do this
and we're going to highly structured way
and i would watch her very very very
carefully that's the main thing if
britney had been engaged in a 12-step
community that's the best news of all
because that community will rally around
her watch her help her support her
educate her about her illness so nothing
from my opinion my standpoint could be
a better sign that her engaged with a
community that she's highly connected
with like a mutual aid society
i just want my life back
brittany's been silenced to speak out
about anything that's really going on
what are your thoughts on the netflix
documentary claiming that her medication
was increased when she was working were
you surprised documentaries are not
medical records right they're a point of
view they're trying to stir the audience
none of it surprises me but when i look
at the documentary i all i see is that
there's lots of missing information we
don't really know what was going on
you're assuming there is some sort of
nefarious intent and the reality is she
had an excellent therapeutic team around
her from the beginning it's why she's
alive that's why she's been so stable
and decisions they were making were on
her behalf now the control of her life
may run afoul of our sense of
a free society and i understand that and
she deserves a chance to try and if she
decompensates on her there were nights
where
she was up and i had to stay home with
her she was taking address so there was
some reporting for taking adderall and
becoming quite manic on that which
people with bipolar disorder that's
taking stimulants is anathema it's the
worst thing they can do the excessive
use of stimulants can damage the brain
but
not on a short term basis and untreated
burned out bipolar disorder can hurt how
your brain develops and ages so it's not
a healthy state to be in that's for sure
but just a short-term decompensation
doesn't really mean anything there are
further allegations that a former
manager was accused of crushing drugs
and putting them in her food he denied
it said she was drug tested and passed
do you have any thoughts on that i don't
know the parameters of her
conservatorship they may have been
within their right to slip medication to
her that may have been part of their
obligation to keep her safe now if they
were giving someone was giving her
illicit drugs
doesn't that help you understand why
jamie spears would be so anxious about
the people that are around her and
wanting to control that that that if i
were the father that would drive me to
distraction constantly so don't mistake
excessive use of medications like
benzodiazepines the reckless use of
medications that can kill people with
therapeutic medication for people with
serious mental illness those those are
not the same universes now i understand
that people are worried about britney
spears and they should be clearly
they're people that are giving her
access to things that are not great for
her but
this therapeutic team that you know got
her the conservatorship put her in the
hospital saved her life make no mistake
about it has it gone too far probably i
am disturbed that the conservatorship
team felt they had to essentially spy on
her but once again we don't know the
parameters the conservatorship they
may have been charged with doing things
like that lest they incur liability if
something bad happened to her that might
have been part of their responsibility
it seems ridiculous it seems excessive i
i don't like it but we really don't know
what their charge was at the time i
think these claims will result in an
investigation and i think they warrant
an investigation because as i've said we
don't know thus the us the public
looking from the outside in
the parameters of this conservatorship
if it didn't include doing things like
such that they had done that was
excessive
that's a problem do you think jamie
could be in serious trouble
in your opinion you've got to put
yourself in jamie spears shoes as a
father who has been concerned about his
daughter with a serious illness for many
many years
if you're the father
and you think you've done what's right
you're probably willing to take those
punches if you've got to sit up and take
the punches on behalf of your child
you'll just do it
so if he's a good guy which i suspect he
is again she's done exceedingly well the
fact that she has been so stable she
hasn't been in the hospital she's been
able to work she now has her own money
that speaks volumes about the the
efficacy
of what her therapeutic team and this
conservatorship has done you know the
part we ought to all watch is what
happens next this may not go well this
and it could even be of life-threatening
proportions she could lose her fortune
everything could go bad she deserves a
chance to do that